Hello.
I'm Julia Chatterley.
And we begin with breaking news
from two locations.
North
Korea has just launched
another suspected ballistic missile.
We'll have more on
all the details on that
in just a moment's time.
But first to Pakistan.
The former
Pakistani prime minister,
Imran Khan, has been shot and injured
His party says an unidentified gunmen
opened fire at a rally putting his foot.
They're calling it
an assassination attempt.
This video was released in
just the past few minutes
showing calm, being helped into a car.
Let's go straight now
to Safia Southey, who's in Islamabad
for us. Severe.
What more do we know about his health
and who else perhaps
was injured in this attack to
Julie?
We know that this happened
in the town of Good Traveler.
We know that Imran
Khan has been shot in the foot.
He's been taken directly
to the main city of Lahore,
one of the largest cities in the country,
which is close to Gujarat.
We also know by members of his party,
the BCCI, that there has been one death,
one person has died
in this shooting
that took place on his convoy.
We've seen images of Senator Fester
Javaid, who is a close associate
of Imran Khan,
who usually travels with him
on these rallies.
He's been shot in the face.
He's asked for people to pray for him.
But we've also been told
that the Pakistan Tehreek
e Insaf, the PTI, Imran Khan's party,
has put out a statement
that this was an assassination
attempt against Imran Khan.
And we are already seeing they charged
speeches and visuals coming out
right of the back
of this attack on the convoy
that was moving
in the province
of Punjab towards
the capital city of Islamabad.
Khan launched this
rally, this
long march about a week ago
calling for early elections.
And he had said
that he fears for his life.
And we've seen for our Chaudhry
former information minister,
a senior party
leader of the PTI,
making very charge statements
that while that party
is a party of peace,
that there will be revenge for this,
the blood of their workers has flowed,
the blood of their leader has flowed.
And it's a very
politically charged atmosphere
in this country,
which is already
very polarized because of the various
political developments
that have taken place here in Pakistan
over the past couple of months.
We're waiting for the interior minister
to start a press conference to explain
who was behind the dark,
what actually unfolded.
There have been visuals
that have been splashed across
all local channels.
We're just trying to figure out
what's actually happened.
But there is without a doubt, the fact
that the convoy of Imran Khan,
a hugely, immensely popular politician
and former cricket player here
in this country,
his convoy has been attacked
and one person is dead
with at least three others injured
apart from Imran Khan.
Julia, very it's interesting.
And you mentioned it.
And it's not just Imran Khan himself,
but those around him
have been concerned
about threats to his life.
And ever since he was ousted
as prime minister, he's
been increasingly vocal
against the incumbent government.
I just wonder
when we're looking at these images,
what security
does he have,
what security around him
and how has that changed
since he was prime minister, particularly
in light of the threats to his life?
And they've been ongoing
Well, Julia, every time we've had press
you know,
press conferences
with Imran Khan, press briefings
with Imran Khan,
we've been told by Khan and we've no
security detail that travels with him.
A private security detail of the attack
also took place
in the province of Punjab
when Imran Klein's party
holds the provincial government.
He has again said that he has
enough security
from the present government in the past
couple of weeks.
The government itself
had said that
he's leading a bloody march.
He this past week, for example,
in Pakistan has been highly polarized.
It's almost like a microcosm
of what's been happening in the past
couple of months.
We had a senior
journalist who had been critical
of the establishment,
who was mysteriously killed.
Assassin was killed by gunshot in Kenya.
We had the director
general of the intelligence
services, Pakistan's
eyes and
doesn't even like to
be photographed
making a press conference appearance.
And for the first time,
Pakistan's history
countering Imran Khan's narrative
a military coup
against the current government.
There has been a complete battle
and it's been an embattled situation
with Imran Khan
calling for early elections, he said.
And I spoke to him
just last month in a briefing
and I asked him that look,
for example, in me,
Imran Khan's rallies,
which gathered
thousands of his supporters.
There was a clash in May
when many of his supporters were tear gas
and had to stop their protest
against the current government.
Imran Khan has said that he wants
the elections,
but also said that
he feared for his life.
So going back to what
you just asked about his security,
the prime minister
has released a statement
saying that,
you know,
he condemns the attack
and there will be a probe into this.
But Imran Khan had already said
in the days and weeks
leading up to this exact
long march
towards the capital that he did fear
for his life. Julia.